[Música]
escala en París Ahí va para la
Bienvenidos a todos a este espacio de
radio Francia internacional y France 24
el número de actos antisemitas en
Francia ha bajado más de un 25% en el
último año esto es 436 una disminución
de ataques siempre es una buena noticia
Aunque hay que relativizar esta cifra
según el consejo representativo de las
instituciones judías de Francia Hoy hace
escala en París Ariela Márquez miembro
del buró ejecutivo de este consejo Ariel
Muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros y bienvenido gracias a usted
bueno 436 actos antisemitas en 2022
frente a 589 en 2021 es una bajada
sustancial Pero por qué relativizan
ustedes esta disminución bueno esta
disminución Es solamente una observación
matemática nosotros seguimos las cifras
desde hace más de 25 años
hice estas cifras siguen una una curva
como sinusoidal alrededor de una media y
la media sigue siendo muy alta y esa
media se traduce en un ambiente de
antisemismo muy muy pesado por eso es
que ralentiza esas cifras además ustedes
también destacan que no se recogen todos
los actos antisemitas en ese registro
porque está por un lado internet y
también por otro lado denuncian que hay
una tal lentitud en la justicia que
bueno Muchos altos antisemitas se quedan
sin sin registrar Qué falla luego
hablaremos de las de internet y las
redes sociales que falla en el ámbito de
la justicia para que sea tan lenta
bueno
las leyes existen pero la dificultad que
tenemos es en su implementación
hay lentitud después hay muy pocas
condenas después es difícil poner queja
sobre todo si es contra su entorno
profesional o de vecinos y eso es muy
difícil y por eso nosotros pensamos y
estamos seguros que ese esas cifras son
muy subaluadas O sea que habría muchos
más más altos si hay un digamos un
entorno que hace que se desanime a la
gente a denunciar cuando hablamos de
actos antisemitas esto van desde
insultos hasta agresiones físicas
incluso hasta asesinatos lo hemos visto
aquí aquí en Francia tienen estadísticas
del tipo de actos antisemitas
que hacemos esas cifras esta estadística
y está disponible sobre internet se va
sobre
o más de 80 páginas con todos los
detalles y son cifras también que están
conjuntas y dados por el Ministerio del
interior francés no es únicamente la
comunidad judía que haces sus cifras son
cifras muy serias oficiales del gobierno
y qué tipo de actos antisemitas se
cometen más más a menudo bueno todo
insultos agresión física robos después
Cómo se dice
acoso acoso
de varias maneras en 2021 Bueno ya
existía internet y bueno la lentitud de
la justicia ya existía
algo se habrá hecho mejor no para que
descienda aunque esté en un nivel aún
muy alto no eso es un fenómeno de la
estadística las curvas suben y bajan
todos los años ya nada que se haya hecho
mejor que haya funcionado mejor esa
disminución se sigue varios años
veremos que hay algo que que anda el
tiempo esas pero cada vez que tenemos
una disminución el año que sigue tenemos
una demandación Cuál es hoy el principal
combustible del antisemitismo en Francia
el principal El islamo radical islamo
política y también el odio de Israel que
ahora llamamos la israelofobia y esto se
traduce en Francia y quieren importar el
conflicto extraído palestino en Francia
hablaremos de esto porque es muy
interesante Pero antes quería
preguntarle En qué se distingue y En qué
se parecen el viejo y el nuevo odio
hacia los judíos en Qué
es que antes era más bien la extrema
derecha hoy en día es más el islamo
radical política que es más bien la
extrema izquierda y En qué se parecen
las víctimas son todo la las mismas
Usted cree que desde la extrema
izquierda francesa se fomenta el
antisemitismo
Ay pero menos que la izquierda
pero en la izquierda radical francesa
política hay antisemitismo hay palabras
que inciten y importan el conflicto
hablan de Israel hablan de los judíos
muy mal y eso
alimenta bueno la primera ministra
Elizabeth Von la primera ministra
francesa fue la invitada en la cena
anual que celebra el Cris allí evocó su
historia familiar especialmente la
historia de su padre que fue deportado a
auschwitz allí logró sobrevivir su padre
pero años más tarde no soportó no esa
situación
tan terrible que había vivido y se
suicidó Elizabeth borna aprovechó esa
cena en el Cris para anunciar nuevas
medidas
lo sabemos la Batalla de los prejuicios
se libran la escuela en algunos centros
no se puede hablar de ciertas cosas no
se puede enseñar todo Incluso se
trivializan algunos insultos no hay que
ignorarlo ni minimizarlo y aún menos
cuando una parte de los niños prefiere
irse de la escuela de la República son
palabras muy muy fuertes las de
Elizabeth Von muchos maestros denuncian
que no se puede hablar ni siquiera del
holocausto que es muy complicado en
ciertos centros Porque ocurre Esto bueno
Es cierto que muchos profesores nos
cuenta la dificultad que tienen a hablar
por competencia
Memorial y todo eso pero la realidad es
que es un problema del círculo familiar
Porque un niño de que tiene 9 años no se
puede oponer naturalmente a su profesor
a la a la a la enseñanza
obligada del dictada por el Ministerio
de la educación Y eso es una cosa que es
más bien en el círculo familiar y están
deformando los niños a muy baja edad el
estado francés ha implementado desde
hace años varios programas en la
educación
ahora Elizabeth born anunció por ejemplo
la obligación para los alumnos de hacer
un viaje por lo menos una vez a un lugar
a un Memorial del holocausto qué piensa
usted sobre estas iniciativas muy
positivas estamos en el nivel del
proyecto Será muy difícil de poner eso
en marcha porque hay que formar los
profesores a una pedagogía adecuada
después hay que formar también los
alumnos antes un viaje durante el viaje
también una dimensión histórica para
enseñar Cómo se construye por ejemplo un
régimen
totalitario totalitario totalitario
también habla de las del odio en las
redes sociales Elizabeth bone en
internet
se puede controlar este contenido porque
se ha desatado el tema de los insultos
antisemitas y otros insultos el racismo
y todo se ha exacerbado en internet es
complicado no controlar las redes no sé
si las empresas están muy por la labor
de de controlar sin censurar es
complicado no sé cómo lo ven desde el
creep bueno es una cuestión de voluntad
política y de ley en Francia tenemos
todas las leyes y Los gigantes de
internet se tienen que conformar con la
ley después hay El problema del nivel
fenomenal de de de de de de de de de
mensajes de odio que hayan en internet
Y eso se puede también controlar con la
Inteligencia artificial y lo hacen y lo
logran con cuando es cuestión de
pedofilia
pornográfica y todo eso lo cuando lo
quieren lo pueden o sea es una falta de
voluntad política según usted en este
caso en el caso de la
voluntad política obligar a conformar
los gigantes de internet con la ley es
un derecho del y es en El poder del
gobierno eso antes hablaba usted de cómo
el conflicto Israel o palestino influye
no en Francia se importa a Francia
yo le quería preguntar se puede ser
crítico con el gobierno de Israel y no
por eso ser antisemitas es decir
No porque se critica Israel se es
antisemita O sí no no totalmente no es
de libertad de expresión es alusión de
democracia y me parece a mí que los
israelís mismo se se ocupan bien de
criticar el gobierno eso no es es
democracia eso lo que es antisemitismo
es cuando se desliga el derecho de
existir para Israel el derecho de vivir
los judíos en Tierra Santa El
antisionismo es antisemitismo
sí pero hay que saber lo que es el
sionismo el sionismo es el derecho de
cada judío de volver en Tierra Santa y
los judíos del mundo entero cada año
dicen una vez por año a la Pascua
el año que viene a Jerusalén eso es un
sueño de volver para varios judíos pero
pero yo no pienso que antisemitismo es
denegar ese ese derecho y eso es
antisemitismo en brevemente ha habido
más personas judías de Francia que se
han ido a Israel desde los atentados
Desde esa ola de atentados que tuvimos
en Francia si observamos un poco pero es
difícil de decir si es falta de a causa
de los atentados porque se fueron en el
mismo año también en 2012 en 2015 y una
alianza se prepara no se
no se van solo por miedo por seguridad
porque él hace la inseguridad existe en
el mundo entero Incluso en Israel
también en Israel también pero lo que
hay en Francia lo que resiente la gente
que se quiere ir es un sentimiento de
indiferencia y de abandono y es muy
difícil de vivirlo ahora la liada se se
hace No solo por causa de antisemitismo
en el mundo es un sueño un proyecto de
vida y Bueno hay varias causas Bueno ya
no nos queda mucho tiempo señora amar y
quería que termináramos con una frase o
una reflexión a modo de conclusión Bueno
cuando hablamos de antisemitismo y el es
su papel de tratar de ese problema
la gente puede imaginar que Francia es
un país antisemita no lo es del todo
Francia es un país donde
antisemitas pero no es antisemita del
todo todo lo contrario tenemos la ley es
adecuadas es como si fuera una
enfermedad el antisemitismo es Es como
si estamos en el estado de de de busca
de investigación y el tratamiento o la
cura Todavía no se ha encontrado Bueno
pues esperemos que se encuentre pronto
Muchísimas gracias señor amar y muchas
gracias a todos ustedes y no queremos
decirles Adiós Sin dar las gracias a
Fabián muñé un técnico que ha estado con
nosotros desde el principio de esta
aventura y le deseamos lo mejor en su
próxima etapa ya saben nos pueden seguir
también por internet en rf y mundo.com y
Flash 24.com Hasta pronto amigos
[Música]
[Aplausos]